hey guys Mary here gamespot.com and I'm
happy to be showcasing games done quick
today will be will be streaming 5 games
for you speed running through them all
and I'm happy to be joined by a few
people from the Giant Bomb crew oh hey
Mary just across the office I'm so glad
you could make pasta glue there's an
arduous journey yeah somehow we made it
through seven whole seconds but more
importantly we have religion here who
will be our speed runner the most
important and you're gonna be
speedrunning fashion for us today in 20
minutes I heard the is the ha faster
than that I didn't even 20 is impressive
let's hear it let's have the goals below
and then exceed expectations alright
it's pretty amazing
we'll show we'll get right into it and
then basically in the standard way once
you say start the timer will have a
timer run for us and we'll just see how
it goes sure thing alright we can get
started anytime
I'll just as soon as I click this button
we'll go ahead and start the timer I'll
give you guys a countdown alright are we
ready with the time right here we get
all right so 3 2 1 go is it safe to talk
to you while you're doing this oh it is
absolutely safe around this game a lot
of this is a world-record attempt here
that will probably come to an end real
soon
yeah what does the world record well
this one uh so this this category that
I'm running so generally in speedrunning
we have a bunch of different categories
that just say you know what goal you're
trying to accomplish and this one we're
just trying to beat the game as quickly
as possible on new game mode and that's
gonna involve a glitch or two the world
record is 13 minutes 58 seconds by a oh
man I don't want to get the wrong
nationality by European speed runner
named house edge there you go he's very
very good good catch all my time is 14
minutes in 10 seconds I'm gonna try to
get under 50 and today I think
it's pretty doable chamber it took me
significantly longer than that oh my god
our games yeah I think my first
playthrough was around 8 hours I just
did it one Saturday I sat down I was
like I'm gonna be at this game
hello game yes this is a fantastic game
I've played over a thousand hours
Oh totally worth every second this board
that I played the dead language you're
saying earlier some people might ask you
if you get bored of the vo or the music
yeah exactly
no you never ever get bored of it again
if you're a speed runner you generally
look the street run games where you are
going to keep enjoying the music and
we've got a game there's exceptions
obviously and there's someone who runs a
game where you just can't stand the
music anymore it's so repetitive
powerful that he just puts on like rain
wave or something
rain wave you squirt stuff you never
know where that no duh music online
radio station like oh god it's pretty
good okay I was actually curious if the
dialogue ever acts as like a useful
timing cue for you I does not before
it's super much however actually there
is get out of my way we are going to add
a couple points we're gonna use the
dialogue to facilitate a couple Oh call
those that will be right there okay okay
just a helpful guy or how about work
yeah Rex's is very special he likes to
say a lot of things and sometimes he
really wants us to listen to whatever it
is he's gonna say I don't get that
person do you know if you can outrun
these panels floating up like is that
just an animation or are they actually
floating up they are actually floating
over looking totally outrun them Wow
multiple times
alright off the actually game yeah it's
actually and that's a good time to
mention I'm playing with mouse and
keyboard intentionally oars it's not
because I enjoy this control net that I
actually would rather play on a
controller
now from keyboard is the fastest
movement method and the reason is that
when you use the mouse to Mouse move and
then you roll while doing that it adds
the speed of your mouse movement onto
your own what you go 30% faster I have
no idea why it works that way it just
does and so we take advantage of it and
you continuously roll through your
movement you never actually pretty much
out of time yeah
there will be a couple places later on
oh by the way gets in this game so
sometimes we're just gonna kind of
ignore their suggestion but yeah there
will be a couple times where I'll
intentionally walk and that is just
because I won't be able to keep rolling
if I do I'll fall falling costs about
two and a half seconds every time I do
so it's better to just walk away let me
so now you're gonna see the first major
glitch I did which is the core that I
just dropped into the monument just
disappeared and that is because I picked
up two cores at the end of this group
that's not really an intended thing in
this I didn't even notice that yeah you
always see it next level I'll I'll point
it out specifically because you'll see
that it will pop up in 100 XP twice
besides when I pick it up next double
the core is unacceptable I'm gonna get
correct solve it on the phone yeah I
think I think Greg has watched some of
these runs I didn't run I guarantee that
he's definitely into super crazy
hardcore stuff like this yeah for sure
and I did a run of us an awesome games
done quick 2014 and of in the middle of
the night but that was kind of I think
the first time people really got to see
this on a big stage it's a really fun
run it's nice to claim a loser
it's going through a lot of changes so
there you might have seen the hundred XP
pop up twice ok leave you logical
excellent to follow I remember when we
were talking to Greg well those guys
were building it and he was he comes
talking about like - cancelling and like
all these like hit boxes and yeah frame
detection yeah those guys are way in the
fighting games and RTS is and all that
stuff so that's interesting
they're definitely they are the
technical mind about game design that
actually kind of
drives with a lot of what I know about
this thing because I built the wrong
building so I'm gonna open this ability
intentionally huh yeah Rex is talking
right now normally when I went to the
Skyway right here he would have tried to
say another line but because he was
already talking he couldn't start that
oh wow
and with him before before exactly if he
had started saying that line he would
have locked me out from traveling but
because he didn't I was able to travel
immediately this is ridiculous
so this is the level where we first see
how likely it is for me to fall off by
just about running the ground and so I'm
gonna walk a fair bit less I'm gonna go
off screen here and kill Tyra to try to
do you'll just have to come to a deal
there was a turn I'm sure he's got so
many questions after all the Tunde
brothers so there I have to walk there's
no other way and here are those ground
there really I promise there's actually
not that many places in the game where
there's just the ground even though
there doesn't appear to be but that one
right near that car you just haven't
ready physically there okay so now we
can just relax for a moment so you guys
got any questions on this brewing in
your head or what kind of skills are you
going to be putting anything into none I
will no it's not doing those skills
I will not be touching any buildings for
any reason I hope into the one building
to get a dialog schism I'm not gonna
bother with any others there's no point
oh just cost too much time to be worth
because there are points where you have
to kill all the enemies right my fish is
no way around at least in the beginning
I mean sure you go past the gates and I
guess you don't what normal people might
have killed okay Oh actually coming up
in cinder brick fort there's one really
good area where you'll see yeah what
what speedrunners think of oh you have
to kill all the enemies your logic has
no place here through this is one of my
favorite levels by the way cinder brick
fort I just love I love the music and
the ambience and the combination of
everything we are this is just
it all really works together so with a
fairly recent game like this art here
this city more like D are you the one
finding out a lot of this stuff Bastion
in particular because it's a very
popular game there are a lot of people
who have worked to improve the speed run
over time okay in fact actually right
here I'm picking up the scrap musket
there is a recent change that a friend
of mine named archives came up with
where you don't pick up the musket and
it has a trade-off that a couple enemies
later on are a little bit slower to kill
but the exchanges that obviously you
don't have to wait for the bus get
notice yeah there are alternate Stratos
to deal with that but I haven't learned
them yet so I didn't think it was worth
wasting and potentially up to a minute
doing the wrong thing here alright so at
the end of this level as we were just
kind of talking about there's a big
arena you're supposed to kill all the
dudes and then you do get through a door
this is the arena we're stuck here we
can't leave until we show all the dudes
that's just one example of how we're
going to totally disregard the game
that's not a video game quirk also we're
about to do a very big glitch here it's
gonna save about 10 seconds I can't
really explain what's going on here but
if I roll off the bastion right there I
just dropped in to shards at the same
time that's it yeah are a lot of these
phones just accidentally and then shared
amongst the community uh accidentally
yeah does tend to be the way a lot of
glitches get found people just you know
they do something kind of out of the
ordinary and it results in something
very weird and then they just analyze
okay what did I do to achieve the thing
that I just did
and they try to reproduce it it's a lot
like like actual video game QA if you
think about it where you just try to
reproduce the bugs but specifically the
beneficial ones now speedrunners record
like all the time so they can go back
and see it okay what did I actually
booze it's fairly common that they do
yeah I mean this is a lot of
speedrunners stream on Twitch so they
always have recordings available ok
whatever they've been doing and a lot of
the speedrunners of course will also
record local and fine later alright so
here we're expected to fight Queen Anne
and unfortunately
I can't just leave so I will actually
fight her I'm going to try to take her
out in Tunis cycle those two pop-ups or
sing again I totally miss them it's ok
it'll take come on so there's actually a
somewhat little-known thing in terms of
casual play you don't have to kill Queen
in you can just do a bunch of damage and
then the Skyway opens and [ __ ] that's
even if you're not glitching correct so
well so I guess I kind of glossed over
this at the beginning but this chord
duplication the entire idea is if you
pick up an item twice on consecutive
frames and you know the game runs at 60
frames a second then you can pick up two
of it and it only as far as we know and
we've tried a lot of things to test this
it only works for up to two you can't
get three before anything like that and
the easiest way to accomplish this as we
bind the interact button to mouse wheel
down just walk up the item and scroll
the mouse wheel fast just like the two
pistols and counter-strike exactly yeah
they say it fill the skies with
what if they patch it that varies a lot
between game the game but generally what
we do in the speedrunning community for
PC games is wise the old patch is
available and it's not like sketchy to
distribute it or anything we all keep
playing on the old version ok but if
it's actually a good topic for when we
play worried because or is a game where
we intentionally play the latest version
where there were some beneficial
glitches on older versions and we
intentionally moved forward because the
dev said we'd prefer that you didn't
distribute the old version and also
we'll try to work with you guys to not
intentionally like it's not remove
things that benefit you unless they're
like really bad was it so big [ __ ] true
exactly so there was like an
out-of-bounds glitch that frequently
happened to casual players and we were
thinking about taking advantage for the
speedrun and the dev said we're gonna
fix it we said okay we'll just we'll
actually divide by that that's that's an
amazing amount of like communication
with your family yeah well you know that
like I can't launched with a
speedrunning achievement it have like
that community in mind from the get-go
yeah and it's very new for there to be
that level of interaction between
deficit there I mean between devs and
players general let alone between
Debrecen a niche community likes yeah I
remember that came out and then actually
Birds right after that which I was like
a straight-up Steve really moved at it
man like because we're doing it like a
new phenomenon it actually is helping
people become aware of games I mean a
lot of people I know when I watched you
you actually learn of new games and I
hadn't thought of playing and then
watching the new speedrun I want to
actually pick them up and get to play
them like a normal person
yeah that's right I think I'll play that
slowly really fun fast that was exactly
the reaction I had with a shovel knight
at agdq this year I had seen it before
but I watched that particular speedrun
it was just so good at entertaining
I wanted to play the game for real I
can't imagine speedrun a game I've tried
it before really hard or the part of the
wait
yeah it really hard casually it's also
really hard speedrunning I so this is
the last level of the game and if you
want to started the clock and working
with crap yeah I guess nice so I just
push lucky off the edge there I guess
you didn't really get to see it cuz that
camera table but it's okay you can
imagine you just kind of jump off the
edge here seven hearts happen things are
rough if you're still on game and you're
stuck in burst on quarry all day long
with everybody who's eye goes off yeah I
don't know some bit character or
something
I know whatever we're not gonna see any
more of him you don't have time to get
attached to anyone in this game Rory is
so valuable don't sing and you miss all
of it it's true there is if you're
wondering there's actually a category
for this game where you do all the
levels and it's just it's called all
Story levels but the idea is just you
don't do core duplication and that
category is closer to like 50 minutes
but it's also really fun do you see a
lot more of the actual game in this
world and you can't like skip cutscenes
or anything are there are there
speedrunners out there who were just
like softly opposed to glitching and
like a wave run games straight for us
it's uncommon I mean there are
speedrunners who just prefer to play
like less glitchy versions of games but
there's not really like most
speedrunners tend to be by the way we
just skipped the orientation by dying on
purpose yes by dying on purpose twice we
ran out of chances to carry on we
restart area and then we exit and reload
the game and you know now we're pretty
much done so are we ready to hit time
yeah it's about 30 seconds what's the
cutoff point when you see credits
alright it's when you click the button
to choose an ending okay okay there's
something I was in about 30 seconds it's
30 seconds after he says now I want to
make sure that Erik Kay who's hitting
times action Ares I don't know he
expected it to be
six minutes earlier five minutes days on
my plane travels with a siren you ready
sounds like they're ready Zia and I
figure you'd done the heavy lifting so
this normally you know very like
emotional moment is kind of a first
thing if it's still shed a tear
guys quick as possible open up the thing
and time all right mister a few minutes
and 17 seconds
well excused that's really something
so I yeah so I we actually started the
timer earlier than we normally would in
the community timing is so accounting
for that we actually did get on your 15
that's what's awesome good I've never
seen that done that quickly well thanks
a lot version if you guys liked seeing
speed runs of any games you will be
happy to know that summer games done
quick 2015 is about to get started and
that's from July 26 through August 1st
and that's an awesome organization they
speedran all sorts of cool games for
multiple days throughout the night -
this is like ongoing it's really or so
and all the proceeds go to Doctors
Without Borders
so it's really cool and I definitely
recommend you guys check that out